Pergunta que eu recebi. Quais seriam os
melhores suplementos para Apps durante e
após crise? Olha só, hoje a gente vai
bater um papo sobre um assunto que muita
gente conhece, mas poucos entendem de
verdade. O episoster, aquela doença que
o povo chama de cobreiro. Sabe quando a
sua avó dizia que tinha uma cobra de
fogo andando pela pele? Pois é, ela tava
falando dessa criatura aí. E o mais
interessante é que a ciência tá
descobrindo que alguns suplementos podem
fazer toda a diferença, tanto na hora da
crise quanto depois da própria. Deixa eu
contar uma coisa que vai te surpreender.
O mesmo vírus que causou aquela catapora
chatinha quando você era criança fica
escondidinho no seu corpo a vida
inteira, tipo um espião adormecido. É o
vírus varicela.
E ele pode acordar décadas depois e
causar o herposter. Imagina só, o bicho
tá lá quietinho nos seus nervos
esperando uma brecha e quando a sua
imunidade dá uma cochilada, seja por
estresse, idade ou alguma doença, ele
aproveita e volta a atacar. Agora vem a
parte que tá revolucionando o
tratamento, a vitamina C. Mas calma lá,
não é aquela vitamina C do suco de
laranja, não. Eu tô falando da vitamina
C endovenosa ou intravenosa aplicada
direto na veia. Estudos recentes mostram
que doses altas dessa vitamina pode
reduzir significativamente a dor aguda e
até prevenir aquela dor terrível que
fica depois a tal da neuralgia
pósherpética. Tem gente que relata
alívio imediato da dor com infusões de
15 g a cada 2 dias. E é muita coisa, né?
Para você ter ideia, isso é mais de 150
vezes a dose diária recomendada. E olha
que bacana, pesquisadores coreanos
documentaram casos de pacientes que não
estavam respondendo aos remédios
convencionais e tiveram um alívio
impressionante com a vitamina C
endovenosa. Sabe aquela sensação de
queimação, tipo choque elétrico, que o
pessoal com herpes ostes sente? Pois é,
a vitamina C ajuda a acalmar esse fogo
todo e o melhor é que ela não só alivia
a dor, como acelera a cicatrização das
lesões. Mas não é só de vitamina C que
vive o tratamento integrativo do
episóos. A vitamina D de dada famosa,
por exemplo, é fundamental para modular
o nosso sistema imune. É como se ela
fosse o maestro da orquestra imunológica
regendo tudo. E tem mais, o zinco, esse
mineral que a galera muitas vezes
esquece, é essencial pra cicatrização da
pele e para fortalecer as nossas
defesas. Você encontra zinco nas ostras,
carne vermelha, semente de abóbora,
aquelas comidinhas gostosas que a gente
às vezes deixa de lado. E a vitamina
B12, essa é a queridinha dos nervos. Tem
estudos mostrando que injeções locais de
B12 podem reduzir significativamente a
dor da neuralgia póspética. É como se
ela fosse um bálsamo pros nervos
inflamados. Tem gente que aplica direto
no local afetado e sente um alívio
danado. Agora eu vou te contar sobre uns
tratamentos mais naturebas que estão
ganhando espaço. Extrato de erva
cidreira, o hipéricum, erva de São João
e até a lavanda aplicados na pele tem
mostrado resultados promissores. É a
natureza dando uma forcinha pra
medicina. Não é que você vai abandonar o
tratamento convencional, mas esses
complementos podem fazer uma diferença
tanto no seu bem-estar. Falando em
alimentação, deixa te dar umas dicas
preciosas. Durante uma crise de herpes
hóstas, seu corpo tá numa batalha épica
contra o vírus. É tipo uma guerra mesmo.
E seus soldadinhos, a célula de defesa,
precisam de munição de qualidade. Frutas
cítricas, kiwi, morango, pimentão, tudo
isso é bomba de vitamina C natural. E
não esqueça dos peixes gordurosos como
salmão e sardinha, que são ricos em
ômega-3 e tem ação inflamatória
poderosa. Agora, deixa eu falar sobre a
lisina com mais carinho, porque esse
aminoácido tem uma história interessante
com os vírus da família Herpes. A lisina
é como um guerreiro silencioso e é um
aminoácido essencial, ou seja, nosso
organismo não consegue produzir e a
gente precisa obter pela alimentação. E
sabe o que que é curioso? Ela compete
diretamente com outro aminoácido
arginina que o vírus do EPS adora usar
para se multiplicar. Imagina assim. É
como se a lisina e a argilina fossem
dois candidatos pututando a mesma vaga.
Quando tem mais lisina no seu corpo,
sobra menos espaço paraa arginina e o
vírus fica meio perdido sem o seu
combustível preferido. Por isso que
muita gente jura de pé junto que a
lisina funciona. E pra simples, aquele
da boquinha realmente tem estudos
mostrando benefícios. Agora exoster a
conversa um pouco diferente. A evidência
científica específica ainda tá
engateando, mas isso não significa que
não vale a pena tentar. Muitos médicos
integrativos recomendam sim a
suplementação lisina durante as crises,
apostando nessa mesma lógica de
competição com arginina. As doses
geralmente ficam entre 1 a 3 g ao dia
durante a fase aguda. E olha que
interessante, você encontra a lisina
naturalmente em vários alimentos
gostosos, queijo, iogurte, ovos, peixe,
frango, carne vermelha. Tudo isso é rico
em lisina. Tem gente que durante uma
crise de herpesóstea capricha nesses
alimentos e evita os ricos em argilina
como chocolate, amendoim, castanhas e
aveia. É uma estratégia nutricional que
pode complementar o tratamento. Uma
canal da lisina é que ela é super
segura, mesmo que a evidência específica
pro episóter ainda não seja robusta,
como é o caso da vitamina C endovenosa,
por exemplo, ela dificilmente vai te
fazer mal. E tem relatos anedóticos de
pacientes que sentiram melhora
significativa.
Às vezes o que funciona para um pode não
funcionar para outro, mas considerando o
perfil de segurança da Lisina pode valer
a pena sob orientação profissional.
E o ácido alfalipoico, esse é um
antioxidante poderoso que tem mostrado
benefícios, principalmente para quem
sofre com a dor crônica depois do
herposer. É como se ele ajudasse a
ressetar os nervos danificados,
diminuindo aquela sensação horrível de
queimação e de formigamento. Deixe
contar o que você deve evitar durante
uma crise. Álcool é veneno pro seu
sistema imune, literalmente. Ele bagunça
sua microbiota intestinal e enfraquece
suas defesas. Gorduras saturadas em
excesso também podem ser problemáticas.
Então, o churrasquinho todo dia não vai
te ajudar. Agora, o negócio é caprichar
nas gorduras boas, abacate, castanha,
azeite de oliva, extra virgem. Sabe o
que que é mais impressionante? O
estresse é um dos maiores gatilhos pra
reativação do vírus. É como se o
bichinho percebesse que você tá
vulnerável e aproveitasse para atacar.
Por isso, técnicas de gerenciamento
estresse não são frescuras, são parte
fundamental do tratamento e prevenção,
meditação, yoga, caminhada no parque,
tudo isso conta. E tem uma coisa que
pouca gente sabe, o herposter pode ser
um sinal de alerta do seu corpo. Às
vezes ele aparece quando algo não tá
legal com sua imunidade. Por isso é
importante investigar se não tem alguma
condição subjacente, enfraquecendo suas
defesas. por exemplo, diabetes mal
controlado, deficiências nutricionais,
uso de certos medicamentos, tudo isso
pode abrir a porta pro vírus. Voltando à
vitamina C, tem um detalhe importante.
Não adianta tomar um comprimidinho de
500 mg e achar que vai resolver.
As doses terapêuticas usadas nos estudos
são muito maiores e muitas vezes
precisam ser intravenosas para alcançar
os níveis necessários no sangue. É por
isso que o acompanhamento profissional é
fundamental, não é coisa para fazer em
casa por conta própria. E olha que
interessante, pesquisadores da década de
40, 1940 já sabiam do poder da vitamina
C contra infecções virais. O Dr.
Frederick Kleenner tratava poliomielite,
pneumonia viral e até encefalite com
megados e vitamina C. A gente às vezes
acha que tudo é novidade, mas muita
coisa boa da medicina foi esquecida e tá
sendo redescoberta agora. Pro pessoal
que já passou pelo herposer e ficou com
aquela dor chata que não vai embora, eu
tenho boas notícias. Além dos
tratamentos que eu já mencionei, a
combinação de diferentes abordagens pode
fazer milagre. vitamina C intravenosa,
alfa lipoico, vitaminas do complexo B,
aplicações tópicas de capsaina. É um
arsenal completo para combater a
neuralgia póspética e não subestim o
poder de uma boa nutrição no dia a dia.
Manter os seus níveis de vitaminas e
minerais em dia é como ter um exército
bem treinado, equipado, pronto para
defender o seu corpo quando necessário.
Vitamina A, vitamina E, selênio, ferro,
cada nutriente tem o seu papel nessa
batalha. E para finalizar a nossa
conversa, eu quero deixar bem claro uma
coisa. O episóster não é brincadeira. A
dor pode ser incapacitante e as
complicações sérias, mas a boa notícia é
que temos cada vez mais ferramentas para
prevenir e tratar essa condição.
Lembre-se sempre, seu corpo é sábio e te
dá sinais. Se você teve catapora na
infância, o vírus tá aí dormindo. Cuidar
da seguridade, manter uma alimentação
equilibrada, gerenciar o estresse e
alguns casos, sim. Considerar uma
vacinação são as melhores formas de
manter esse bichinho quietinho onde ele
deve ficar. E se ele resolver aparecer,
agora você sabe que tem muito mais
opções além dos antivirais
convencionais. A medicina integrativa tá
aí para somar forças e te ajudar a
passar por isso com menos sofrimento e
mais qualidade de vida. Yeah.